it was all destroyed by Russian tanks
awesome liberators
I was born in this house please turn off
the bright light the Russians can see us
I hate the Russians for turning my quiet
Paradise my little Laman into war zone
it was absolutely disgusting you can see
your childhood home and you see it raped
so to say to be honest I still feel the
smell of strangers in my house
is and always will be Ukraine because Le
Mans is an old Kazakh City
in that District behind the residential
neighborhood they already have
electricity
but there probably won't be a guess
right all the pipes are trashed that's
the way things are this is my icon of
Saint lubov and my grandson's icon of
survive everything will be fine
territory Community numbered about 40
000. Can you estimate how many people
are left now in limang about seven
thousand just about and this was the
house itself right well this here this
was a house and this was yeah this was a
log cabin here where do you plan to live
now you can't plan anything
whatever the future brings where we will
serve there we will live
and in the spring we will have victory
and a peaceful sky and we'll work to
restore the damage that the Russians did
here
we are now going to Le man to survey the
destruction which the Russians caused
here and how the man's deoccupation took
place
it happened more than a month ago
but we have only managed to get here now
let's try to find people in the streets
mostly to talk to them
and we also have several contacts in the
man
let's hope they will find us
people who are directly involved in the
deoccupation
I made some kind of resistance or at
least those who can tell about what the
Russians were doing here during the
months while the man was occupied
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
was planned here but was never completed
and this is our gymnasium
what's left of it
when did the war start for you in 2014
my elder brother joined the army later I
joined as well he was discharged in
2018. then he signed a contract one more
time
in 2021 and was discharged again due to
his health
when three months ago
there used to be a gym where now there's
a pile of debris there's even a ball
laying there somewhere
we are trying to clean the city
this was all the gyms area
that's it
just the walls are left and that's it
the first floor still stands more or
less
the whole has survived there and then
there are only walls left
the upper three floors were destroyed
tell us what the 24th of February was
like for you
I was on holiday in February
since the first of February we didn't
wait for the 24th we were called back
from our vacation and met the Russian
army Dooley
my battle line included
[Music]
we did not give up a centimeter of our
land to the Russians in that area
on March 1st as an artillery unit we
were targeted by an airstrike
as one of the commanders said they are
utterly inaccurate Shooters they
completely missed
all troops were unharmed and everything
was fine
did you return to liman after it was
deoccupied
yes I've been here for about two or
three weeks
how did you get back what was the first
thing you saw here what can I see
Devastation what can I see here
everything everything in Ruins why is it
so important to return here now to
restore the city
who else but us as paratroopers say who
else but us
what is your role in the restoration I
work at the citizen security Center
in our communal Institution
now we are helping the local people to
restore everything
nice
Putin voodoo doll
I think it's more about the system that
exists in Russia it seems to me that not
much depends on this one's comeback it's
more of a symbol
there is indeed a large system they were
killing us a century ago and they're
killing us now
yes I agree
foreign
how are people here some people say
thank you for coming thank you for
Liberation and some people look at you
as unfriendly
you can feel their attitude right away
you can for sure
launching can you hear it yes it's a
barrage of mlrs garud how far are the
Russians from Le Mans now could they hit
us with a grand missile here not with
God no they are targeting the city with
Oregon and missiles the day before
yesterday the city was bombarded with
missiles can you understand why Russia
started this full-scale Invasion at all
this was all planned this was planned a
long time ago but why now then
I can't answer
there's a road to the right after the
bus stop
this was all destroyed by a Russian tank
liberators
they liberated the people from
everything they had
they did should I park somewhere here
yes please
I was born in this house so to say I see
I grew up here now let's go and see
what's left of it
be careful
please turn off the bright light
we're going upstairs and we don't need
any beacons
what I mean is that there is a straight
road and the Russians might see us they
are pretty close
then I'm turning on the flashlight but
I'll point the light beam downwards
please avoid any light in that direction
this is my apartment
it's mine in Mom's
okay
some belongings were evacuated and some
were looted I see did they live here yes
my mother and grandmother used to live
here I mean the Russians when they came
here or had they destroyed the building
by that time they definitely were here
those comebacks see everything is
trashed our fathers used to be here and
now they're gone
uh
one of the locals guided the Russians
here
showed the apartment and told them who
was in the photos do you blame anyone in
particular you know we have the
presumption of innocence
do you think that concept still applies
during martial law
not really
sure I believe that our state does not
need people like that
one of the
foreign
such houses are certainly not subject to
repair right not really no
no
let's go upstairs oh books yes my mom
had a large book collection oh I have
the same book about Dynamo FC
about what about football about the
football club Dynamo Kiev or that one my
flashlight has run out of power can you
like that one it's just easier my
brother is really into football
you can switch on the flashlight just
point it downwards not upwards they left
a Ukrainian national football fans scarf
and uh one of the football clubs in
Emperor
Unfortunately they looted the football
club scarf
let's go to another apartment I'll show
it to you
this is the landscape
yeah just a second who has the light
let's go with that light with no light
exactly okay good
this used to be a living room aha whose
apartment was this
one of our brothers serves
I broke into my own garage I had to do
so because the door was welded and you
know there was a lot of other people's
property
so the Russians use private garages to
hide the property they looted from other
people
yes
all locals almost all of them were
Railway employees
Luman was uh
used to be a major Railway Hub well
there was also a Depot and a repair shop
yes that's right as far as I'm concerned
its operators are now being suspended
but there are plans to restart an
electric train
s
these are the doors
remained undamaged
those writings were left by the Russians
this is a piece of military equipment
they used
that's it no stock left
the Russians knew that we joined the
army that Mom someone tipped you off
right yes someone did they knew that
Mama's both sons went to defend Ukraine
there's not a single item left
it was all looted
this place was littered with tins and
Russian canned food
they probably live somewhere right
around here yeah they did yes we saw
someone's tactical vest which means that
they were here
I see there's even a piece of some bun
it's probably one of their jackets right
no it's mumps
surprisingly they didn't loot it
they love to steal women's clothing
they left the kettle
and didn't steal it
took the pewter she had here as well
there's only a mouse left from the
computer but with no batteries
with no batteries
who needs it
foreign
we did not go anywhere and lived in the
basement
we were lucky that the fighting lasted
just from late
spring until early summer now it's
quieter here and no explosions are heard
some are far away but not here
how do you plan to survive through the
winter
well
some people have Potbelly stoves which
will install and others will mainly stay
in the basement we were promised that
the power supply would be renewed soon
the city mayor came here and promised to
renew the power supply in two or three
days
in the district behind the residential
neighborhood they already have
electricity yes Vietnam but there
probably won't be any gas right
everything is destroyed all the pipes
are trashed
that's the way things are
tell us uh do any volunteers come to
your District at all do some
organizations help
yes the volunteers are coming and they
bring some humanitarian Aid
we live thanks to it there is no work
there is nothing seven months with no
work we rely on
you might turn eight alone to live
there's no salary nothing at all I used
to work as a mechanical engineer on the
railway now there's no Railway anymore
everything is gone everything is ruined
everything's burnt down
are there many people left in this
neighborhood
about 100 people in the area
look at the camera
maybe one of your owners will see you in
the video
[Music]
this is my icon of Saint lubov and my
grandson's icons
is this activity does this calm you down
having at least something to do yeah
yeah that's right do you live here alone
my son left
here I'm knitting
have you caught many mice here no this
was the first one I put a cup there for
the moment
I wanted something else
children were staying here
we call this room
two children
a grandfather
they were sleeping here these bunk beds
or once I call them I don't know
and how old were the children
nine and twelve years old everyone here
had their own room I guess everyone
arranged the room the way that uh no way
one could what everyone had for that
when the Russians were bombarding 37
people used to live here
yeah
um
my room is like a world of its own
this is our bicycle storage oh tell me
more about it we've noticed that
everywhere in the deoccupied territories
we've been to bicycles are vital isn't
that right our city has a north and a
South District here we have very few
Standalone houses
these types of neighborhoods are mostly
in the North District when you're going
to a cottage the easiest thing is to get
on a bicycle and ride when you go back
to your flat you can load whatever you
need on the bike and cycle back this is
our shower room
some garlic to stay healthy right yeah
some garlic onion carrot beetroot are
all there the so-called borscht set you
bet
not sure and so should we go let's go
serious boom everything is bummed out
foreign
I'll tell you the truth empty cans of
Russian tin food are scattered all over
the yard now those people who wanted the
Russian World now they can fully
experience it but us with my dog Willie
Ukrainian can meet
good luck thank you all the best we
didn't leave the basements we were
hiding there it was really hard
especially for one's uh mental health
the missiles in the air but where's it
aimed at will it fall or won't it
something is in Flames something is
exploding people are dying it was very
hard many people left they abandoned
everything so this year where can we go
to go somewhere is to cause discomfort
to someone to make someone share their
home with you and here we make it
through somehow planting some crops
growing something eating hoping that
there'll be some rain thank God we could
water the plants
that's the way we live and we'll Live
This Is Our Land where else could we go
if someone leaves the land then what
remains is empty land and that's it
someone has to stay under any conditions
no matter how hard it is
we will survive
everything will be okay
[Music]
I couldn't believe
that lemon
would be like this
again after 2014.
could you recall your personal
experience how did it happen what
direction did you enter the city from
how did you get to your house
we're an official combat unit we were
carrying out specific missions and you
know being in Le Mans and not stopping
by to see my own house of course I
couldn't walk past it
the most emotional moment
we are coming to see my house
mom left the clothes hanging to dry when
she left
the windows sashes got blown off but the
frame while the window frame seems
intact
I was lucky to say the least that my
childhood home survived and was almost
physically intact I mean several windows
were shattered and window sashes were
blown off but if you look at the
neighboring houses then of course many
houses are not there at all they burnt
down and many were half burnt
I mean I was really lucky
on the other hand I was also unlucky
because Russian collaborators from the
so-called special unit of the ministry
of internal affairs of the DPR typhoon
or based in the house
there are definitely not our clothes
foreign
[Music]
they used it as their base and they were
behaving as a matter of fact like pigs
when we entered my house we saw that
they were about 10 15 people living
there they alluded some of my belongings
because there were still some and my
mother's things were stolen I saw a pile
of household appliances packed in the
house some of my household appliances
were missing by the way it seems that
there is no washing machine either
Russian polluting classics classics they
have a fetish for washing machines
everything was looted from the drawers I
don't get it why do they need my old
sweaters I didn't live in Le Mans at
that time there were some clothes left
there so when I visit uh home I to see
my mom I had something to wear and all
those clothes were far from being new
why would they steal those you can buy
in Second Hand Shop you know it makes
your heart feel heavy because you see
you see basically your child is home you
see it raped so to say and the first
night we arrived here we decided to stay
overnight because it was already getting
dark and we didn't really want to go
anywhere at night we decided to spend
the night there because we still had
certain tasks for the next day in Le
Mans and it was morally challenging when
you spend the night in your own house in
your own room and the bed sheets smell
of strangers and you have this feeling
that your house was raped I mean
there are some other people's belongings
there half of your belongings have been
taken away or they are just scattered
somewhere
from a moral point of view
it was absolutely disgusting
I say that I still be honest feel the
smell of strangers in my house The
Equalizer action film it's not ours
either
what are these CDs they're not ours
constantly send my regards to rostik on
social media he is their Commander
fifties
now I will live in your place
forgetting your personal documents in
the house where you squatted is a bit
weird overall they looted everything
their regrouping must have been very
abrupt
yes yes two abrupt indeed when Mom fled
and she really fled quickly and there
was no time to in small towns you know
cats live as they want they have their
own schedule mom waited for the cat
waited for him but then she had to leave
quickly because the car was already
waiting for her I'm ashamed to admit it
but she had to leave the cat there and
when the cat saw me again he recognized
me to be honest I even cried a little
bit because the cat is a cat every
Ukrainian knows what a cat means to us
sacred animal yes exactly oh my God
Kitty is feel so sorry for you we
abandon you poor boy
the neighbors held certain patronage
over him and were feeding him that is he
was not all alone there
a Ukrainian journalist Michael sure
recently got canceled for abandoning his
cat what about cat he joined the cat
territorial defense that's the way we
imagined it that is I had to I was
departing at nine in the morning I was
at the recruiting office and got a
weapon when I left I realized that I had
taken everything except the cat his name
is akit akit I'm sorry I just abandoned
him on the street
why will Russia fail because we are
strong United and because even after
eight months have passed we believe in
our Victory we act for our Victory and
we know what we are fighting for for
one's family one's home one's district
one city one's Ukraine and the Russians
are fighting for some incomprehensible
nonsense
the hell knows what against some
fascists although they are indeed the
real fascists we will win because
wherever we are I mean us and our units
we have tremendous support from our
local people tell me please do you need
any help from us how can we help you
you've already done everything for us
I bow to the ground for you
for your children for your women for
your parents I bow to you
we are fighting for light and they are
fighting for darkness and therefore we
will win thank you
thank you
[Music]
all kinds of Russian attacks despite all
kinds of Russian Wars and despite the
fact that Russians are rushing here
Lamont was is and will always be Ukraine
because Le Mans is an old Kazakh City
tell us your story I believe we should
start by telling about the 24th of
February right
when it all started our country woke up
from the airstriks Le man was no
exception
did the first missiles strike here too
the first missiles did not hit Le Mans
and the Russians targeted slovenians
still the explosions were Extremely Loud
after a peaceful period
well I can't say that it was a peaceful
period in dumbass but the borders of the
war were a little different and then
there were these airstrikes and
everybody woke up
this was our Krusty lemon forestry there
was one and there will be there will be
for sure it will be after reconstruction
like before the war
Lino they used to call it the gem of the
Donovan
many forests and lakes I'm talking about
the trevonioskill reservoir and Blue
Lakes
former quarries
where the water is still very clean and
pure all the cremators and slavians
locals were coming here on vacation
Before the full-scale War the government
made every effort to develop local
tourism what was the population of liman
before the start of the full-scale
invasion the lament turtle community
numbered about 45
000. the figure includes both City and
adjacent areas
Can you estimate how many people left
here now
about 7 000 people just about
[Music]
um
officially began on May 23rd
until now the war continues
we've been helping people as much as we
could
as much as we had resources
we had been evacuating them and
providing humanitarian Aid
we have been explaining what's going on
to the locals and not only to them but
also to the Personnel everyone thought
it would be like 2014.
every day I communicated with my troops
and I kept saying that this is not 2014
guys
we couldn't sit back
and we had to do something
special it's no secret in here in the
bus the way of thinking about Russia and
the West
may be quite different yeah and they saw
these people probably saw a friend in
Russia and my task as I understand it oh
now uh we are passing the state
emergency service yesterday there was an
airstrike there wait uh can you see it
the S 300 Missile hit
The Head of the State emergency service
was resting there it was midnight and
the shards of glass cause injuries
did he get injured yes in the head yet
it didn't Target the building but hit
nearby he got lucky lucky indeed
so every day I would tell them
that it would not be the same as 2014.
and it paid off
98 of my personal remained true to their
oath and there are only three people who
stayed who stayed here
that is they did not follow the order to
evacuate they did not follow the
evacuation order exactly
yep there is such a Russian narrative
that those who evacuate in fact give up
on the city
they blame local authorities for fleeing
local police forces and so on
can you explain to such people why the
police should evacuate
when it's certain that the occupation is
already approaching
I sworn off to my country in 2001.
why should I break it in 2022
I don't get that
here is this way of thinking let's say
short-sighted people they think that if
you run from one country to another it
is okay
however
we know these people are not welcome in
any country
Traders are all alike if they betrayed
once
again
over and over yeah that's true
what was the occupation like how did it
begin here in May
I'm not a soldier I know that after the
Russians captured criminal troubles came
the airstrikes in the city became more
frequent when the Russians captured Le
Mans they filmed some stage content here
they searched for their golotters
supporters and minions who would tell on
camera that it was all the Ukrainian
troops who were bombing allegedly the
Ukrainian troops deployed there in the
city center and deliberately bombed
their own positions that's such an
absurd vision of the situation
that's what the Russians usually do
actually
yes I know people who share this opinion
and we're staying here during the
occupation by the Russian troops and
when the Ukrainian Defenders were
already on the offense
they all fled to Russia godspeed them
Russia is vast let them go and explore
Siberia and
foreign
after its deoccupation
second or third of October I don't
remember
a month uh has already passed more than
a month
after its official Liberation we arrived
here the next day
and they also fled from here that is
they did not believe
they fled yeah
as we were entering the city there was a
destroyed armored vehicle Convoy on the
road sideline between the village
streets in LeMans they left their
wounded who died there
there was about 15 of them
look at what happens to you when you
come to Ukraine watch and remember what
every Russian Beast will lie down like
these bastards here are two [__] here
are two more [__]
uh you are a donbass local uh how will
common in the situation when these
scumbags are lying down here the
Russians are [__] [__]
I see did you have some kind of tankier
yes and this used to be a fireplace
and this was the house itself right no
yeah no this uh here this was a house
and this was and there was a log cabin
ah everything burned to the ground
[Music]
there's nothing left
someone lives here right there is a dog
this was a neighbor
I don't know where she is now there were
neighbors there you can see their house
burned down completely
where do you plan to live now
I don't know
you can't plan anything
whatever the future brings
where we will serve that we will live
and work
the daughter
just loving someone else 's kitchen over
there where the grass is tall are your
grandchildren with you
that they evacuated they're somewhere in
Odessa
I am empty-handed now but I will give
you some money why what am I to do with
that
and I'll bring you some bread
someone even get here they don't bring
bread
okay I'll bring some bread tomorrow
oh I got used to it already but it's
still scary
scary as I look at it
why did Russia fail to gain a foothold
here maybe their plans have changed
since such a powerful offensive of our
military took place no one expected that
there would be an offensive in Harkey
region everybody was expecting the one
in the south
yes the Harrison region and everyone was
expecting that the main counter-attack
would be around here soon
you see we outplayed them
we were not be yet
everyone was uh so skeptical about about
the counter-attack
we started moving around mid-september
around September 12th 13th that is they
had time to pack and flee nevertheless
they left the information about their
filtration actions yeah they left it the
list of the servicemen in school number
four and some numbers
and here are those long lists you know
everybody you know what that means I
found all the data of those who betrayed
the Ukrainian troops in this notebook
yes those who disclose their personal
information are you taking it away money
money they forgot it
or there was no opportunity to take it
they needed a place for the looted
washing machines and underwear
we witnessed I'm stealing the washing
machine here they had a bus a school bus
and another bus there that's where they
had the solar panels
everything they looted and they brought
it here
according to locals there were about
three to four troop rotation waves
the combat units of the Russian army
were the first to enter the city
and Pakistani recruits were the second
to enter there and the third or fourth
wave was the so-called DPR and LPR
Fighters and each wave was different
according to the locals
they would set a New Order each time yes
they would if we take for example
and other nationalities they had their
own agenda
vodka and local women
that is
there was violence
sexual violence and physical violence
for their part the LPR and DPR
specialized in property theft
and many people suffered from these
actions
the law of Ukraine has returned to lemon
and now you know
there will be water electricity and the
economy will function again the streets
and the houses will be rebuilt and life
will get back to normal do you know why
because the Armed Forces of Ukraine have
come back what are the first steps when
the occupation takes place
many people read and watch us from
abroad other European countries did not
experience the process of deoccupation
since World War II what activities take
place what is the first thing the police
should do when the D occupation process
starts
first of all we spent a whole day on the
first day we arrived we had the task of
restoring some kind of human conditions
for work
there were piles of waste from their
style
it seemed that the Russians relieved
themselves in the same place where they
ate and slept we took out two truckloads
of trash after them oh gross
yes on the second day we started
activities prescribed in our law of the
National Police
were there people here who helped adjust
artillery fire engaged in some kind of
partisan activity
did any such people stay here
those who helped us yes yes
there were a lot of them every day
voluntary people called their relatives
acquaintances and close ones whoever
they could reach and those local people
were helping us
they have been helping us a lot
and this work is still being carried out
in luhan's Christian
the railway connection cannot be
restored yet the bridges are ruined
there right
it's top area did the Russians come here
by kupians did they have a railway
connection
they didn't restore it no didn't use it
no they they didn't they never had a
plan to restore the railway here
the first thing they did was take out
all the Machinery to the city of
dabasova
and the locals who stayed here thought
that the Russians would come
and give everyone a nice job and that
they would work here and have a decent
salary however compared to the peaceful
times
they used to earn
much more back then when Ukraine
controlled these territories
among them there are probably many
people whom you knew personally whom you
met one way or another
can there be any forgiveness for them
maybe someone out of fear waved the
Russian flag when Russia came
here and as Ukraine returned
in my opinion everyone should receive
the punishment they deserve according to
the laws of Ukraine
mm-hmm
the Russians ripped off and took the
Crimea peace with them the pieces from
this area were scattered all around the
room we collected them back and ordered
a new Crimean piece that will arrive
soon Crimea and her son region
and uh
yeah here's one
we found harkive donation
anyway we will restore everything it's a
Pity that we have to pay such a price
for all this
now we have fixed the heating on the
first floor we will not heat the Upper
Floor because there's not enough power
in the boiler that is we will close it
shut until spring and then we will come
up with something and in the spring we
will have Victory and a peaceful sky and
we will work to restore the damage that
the Russians did here
thank you
foreign
and I really like that most of the
people there are ukrainians speaking and
in fact quite open
it seems to me that very often it
depends
we travel around already deoccupied
parts of Donetsk region
in various cities everything depends in
particular on the local Administration
on what it was like and what kind of
public initiatives there were in the
city
there is a feeling that the local
authorities and the territorial
Community
immediately began to work out a plan
for how they would defend
and then deoccupy
and it had a significant impact on the
people in this community
in some places where the local
government turned out to be
collaborators
people believe them
and continue to trust the government
they elected
therefore the issue of direct democracy
in the deoccupied territories
will be of the highest importance
currently the local Administration heads
are appointed
especially where the former mayors
collaborated with the Russians
in some territories where there were
collaborators in power
there are still many people among the
locals who sympathize with the Russians
yes I am from Russia myself are we
enemies no one blood one land who
divides us
and how exactly these people will go on
voting
determining their future and making the
same mistake bringing the Russian world
it's a huge question
to be honest I don't have an answer to
it
it seems to me that direct elections
should not take place for quite a long
time in such territories where the
locals voted for collaborators
however this is my opinion
the man left a hard impression on me you
walk the streets of a once beautiful
city and realize it is basically in
Ruins now
I did not see any undamaged buildings
and it would seem absurd but in such
apocalyptic conditions
people who refused to evacuate
everyone has their reasons for that
and they have been living in dark
basements for more than half a year
sleeping there cooking food on the fire
in the yards
and booming themselves by the fire and
self-made tens
and it's all so sad and terrible because
you know there are countless places like
Le Mans in our country now
I had the impression that LE man is some
kind of exclusion Zone from stalker I
felt like I was in a film because
because people walk around with
flashlights and live in Cellars
they live they live in their sheds they
take their portable stoves outside and
they warm themselves next to these
stoves
stray dogs and cats are running
everywhere outside two dogs even
attacked me they tried to bite me and I
had to run inside the building to hide
what's essential for me in the story
about Le Mans the very history of the
occupation and the occupation of the
city reminds everyone that ukrainians do
not forget their own people and always
will come back to the places they were
forced to leave due to the Russian
aggression and it's crucial that we've
managed to talk to many different people
everyone even those who had some
pro-russian views they thanked us they
were really glad that journalists were
coming here
they basically
welcomed us
thanks to Ukraine thank you bye all the
best but of course they had their own
position they had their own vision of
what was happening
they didn't want the war to continue
because it affected them personally
these are all our people they've been
waiting for Ukraine and we're all very
happy that now the Ukrainian authorities
are here again
two or three years ago with the
Ukrainian team we recorded the
testimonies of witnesses of the
apollodomo
they seem to be very similar to the
testimonies that are emerging now
which we are currently recording from
eyewitnesses of the Russian occupation
we didn't take it out to the city no one
ate it so there it was
chickens and cows urinated and defected
on it on those piles until the grain
rotted
so it was taken away from the people it
was taken away and it got spoiled but
they didn't give it back to the people
no they didn't give it back to people
property is taken away from people in
the same way as it was taken back then
the property is simply destroyed so
people do not have a chance to use it
for example Russians shoot at each and
every solar panel enter a hotel and
shoot all the TVs they can't loot them
because those devices are fixed to the
walls
they just shoot at them so other people
can't use them anymore
it's clear that you if you have a bullet
in your TV screen you won't be able to
repair it
and during the holiday more they did the
same thing but with food
did you have millstones we did in our
Cellar were you hiding them yes we were
were they forbidden the patrolman would
break any Millstone so that nobody got
flowers
why do you think they would do that
no to take away the bread the smother
Ukraine whenever I recollect those
events whenever I ask myself why the
answer is always the same to kill
Ukraine
testimonies about tortures were very
similar too and many more
this suggests that this genocide is
never really stopped
it was just pause
and as long as the world does not
recognize
only 17 countries have recognized as a
genocide of ukraines
and Russia of course did not recognize
did not repent and did not pay us a
single penny of reparations the genocide
goes on it will continue until Russia
begins to pay for all its evil
and our task is to make Russia pay for
all of this is
I want to tell you one more thing we had
a walk with one of the heroes in the man
a former military serviceman and now
head of the communal institution of
limang engaged in the Reconstruction of
the city
we will walk around his apartment which
was basically destroyed and looted
in many places he would ask us not to
turn on the headlights not even to turn
on the flashlight
and we were driving around in the dark
and filming a lot in the dark simply
because all these places were being
watched foreign
and they could just shoot us if they saw
that we were in that place with a
flashlight
they could have thought that it was the
military and thrown something at us
that's why we sometimes take quite a lot
of risks during filming
but in fact in situations like that it
seems to me that we always have a very
cruel harmony with the team
no one panics and we certainly feel the
reason why we are doing it yeah such
testimonies
we don't record them afterwards and
everything has already passed and there
is silence
and you have the opportunity to find out
the way something has happened
no you are doing that at the very moment
when the fighting continues
and those experiences are very sharp
is very important
um
launching
foreign
it's an aircraft I think we also compile
all the stories we have collected
those that are included in these series
and those that do not come out yet
because there is something we cannot
show right now
um we compile all that and later develop
an archive of the war
we are creating it together with docud
days NGO
later this walk I will also become
available to a large number of
documentarians and people who work with
these type of video photo archives
and this is also crucial because for
example
if we talk about a lot more we have a
series of explainers
while we were working on this topic we
realized that there are no archived
materials
there are simply no video archives and
we are just fortunate that some photos
from the times of the whole demore have
survived
this is a huge trauma and our national
tragedy which was silenced for more than
60 years which hashed up in families and
any archives were destroyed
while Germany admitted and paid for the
Holocaust of the Jews the Soviet Union
kept all this information hidden from
the world
and as the legal successor of the USSR
Russia recognizes the fact of the famine
but flatly refuses to recognize the
whole of the more as genocide against
the Ukrainian Nation obviously this
would mean destroying the thesis of
fraternal Nations forever the position
of the USSR did not allow recognizing
the millions of victims just as a
position of Russia still does not allow
recognizing the annexation of Crimea and
the actual occupation of part of dunbas
Walter Durante who used to glorify
Stalin and call the thousands of dead
unnecessary collateral costs is still
listed among the Pulitzer Prize winners
nowadays his name does not cause
Applause but stands next to the crimes
of the Soviet regime
when Walter Durante received the
Pulitzer Prize Jim who were covering the
holiday more
considered freaks
who did not like the Soviet Union
for some awkward reasons
the most important thing that I'd like
to do is to thank the Armed Forces of
Ukraine for their invincibility for the
fact that the deoccupation of Ukraine
continues and I believe that very soon
all of Ukraine will be free I thank the
Armed Forces of Ukraine friends if you
like what we do give us a like and write
a comment because it helps this video to
be promoted
you can also subscribe to our patreon
page
support what we do and we will do more
for you
[Music]
thank you